une session capitale pour l'avenir de la
Bourgogne franchecé au conseil régional
les rôles de Dijon et Besançon sont
définis aujourd'hui vous avez suivi les
débats en direct sur notre site internet
retrouvons tout de suite Catherine
emziri et Éric
siico bonjour bonjour à tous session
importante ici au conseil régional de
Bourgogne franchecé puisque les élus
vont se prononcer sur l'organisation
territoriale de la nouvelle région il
s'agit du vote sur le nom sur le
cheflieu défini sur le siège de la
région Catherine oui tout à fait c'est
ce qu'on appelle l'organisation
territoriale Marie GUID du faet a
proposé que puisque Dijon était ville
préfecture Besançon accueillit le siège
du Conseil régional elle a proposé
également 17 directions de ces service à
Dijon et 12 à besonçon alors la
présidente souhaitait un débat serein
mais cette matinée a été émaillé
d'incident le groupe Fond national a
perturbé l'Assemblée en exhibant
notamment le drapeau britannique en
soutien au brexit retour sur l'ambiance
de cette matinée avec Catherine avec
Christophe Taris pardon et Amélie
Douet une session capitale après
plusieurs semaines de querell entre
Dijon et Besançon l'heure est venue de
dessiner la Grande Région et de
retrouver une sérénité cher à Marie
guide duf c'est un moment fondateur et
je l'appréhende très sereinement sereine
même par rapport au vote il y aura pas
de dissension à l'intérieur de la
majorité j'ai toujours dit que j'avais
une belle majorité donc vous êtes
sereine je suis sereine oui et il y a
quelques excès dans les débats et pour
moi ce qui est excessif est assez
insignifiant mais la sérénité se fissura
alors que le Front national sortait des
drapeaux anglais pour saluer le brexit
et soffusquer du nouveau règlement
intérieur le ton est vite monté ben
faites retirer les drapeaux faites-les
retirer vous aussi hein bien sûr ah
madame la Présidente vous êtes la
Présidente c'est vous qui avez la police
de l'Assemblée ce n'est pas à nous de le
faire dit que c'est lamentable une
suspension de séances plus tard et les
débats pouvaient reprendre avec le vote
sur la répartition des rôles en jeu à
droite il y aura des dissensions le
groupe raconre par joyand c'est pas
parce qu'on a pas tout ce qu'on veut
qu'il faut refuser ce qu'on nous propose
voilà donc moi je pense qu' dans ce
dossier effectivement des avis
divergents dans notre groupe bon on va
gérer ça en tout cas moi je reste sur la
ligne que j'ai toujours exprimé Besançon
ne peut pas rien avoir faut quandme
fr sidentif à cette nouvelle région
besanon deviendra donc ce soir le siège
de la Grande Région à Dijon le
cheflieu qui est
donné alors retour ici au conseil
régional en direct avec les trois
présidents de groupes qui nous ont
rejoint Jérôme Durin pour la gauche
François Sadet pour la droite et le
centre et puis Sophie mont pour le Front
national Sophie Montel on vous a
beaucoup entendu sur le brexit on vous a
vu sortir des drapeaux mais finalement
vous êtes peu intervenu sur l'organis
territoriale c'est que ça ne vous
intéresse pas non je crois tout
simplement que vous m'avez pas écouté
parce que j'ai expliqué que le groupe
Front national justement seppositionnait
de manière tout à fait claire que nous
allions voter pour l'organisation
territoriale telle qu'elle nous est
proposé à savoir la capitale régionale
et la capitale des assemblées restant à
Dijon et le site institutionnel avec un
certain nombre que c'est justement parce
que vous soutenez Marie GUID du faet que
vous avez vous avez fait diversion avec
des petits drapeau de la Grande-Bretagne
cétait pas vraiment à l'ordre du jour il
y a quand même un sujet d'actualité qui
est essentiel semble-t-il c'est quand
même le résultat du référendum en
Grande-Bretagne on peut on a Dr par loin
ici à Digon oui mais ça aura quand même
une influence
croyez-moi non je reviens sur ce que sur
ce que vous dites nous n'avons pas voté
parce que c'est une proposition de Marie
gu du faet durant la campagne des
élections régionales nous avions
expliqué justement qu'il fallait un
équilibre territorial entre Besançon et
Dijon donc nous respectons notre nos
propositions de et tout votre tout votre
groupe va voter oui oui oui oui tous
tous même ceux qui n'avaient pas très
envie mais on s'en fiche tous bon
François S vous par contre le le groupe
est partagé ça veut dire qu'il y a des
différents politiques non il y a pas de
différence simplement on a débattu entre
nous une position majoritaire s'est
exprimée pour ne pas souscrire aux
orientations de Madame Duffet parce que
précisément ce qu'elle nous propose est
absolument insensé c'est avoir un siège
de la région à Besançon dans lequel
personensé c'est parce qu'alin joyandé a
l' a l'air de penser et les élus de
droite de fr compé V voter pour les élus
vous verrez pas tous les élus vous
verrezexprime moi j'exprim j'exprime une
position majoritaire du groupe et on a T
majoritaire à combien de voix parmi les
25 vous constaterez après vous meinvitz
après madame mais vous minviterez après
je su pas obligé de tout vous dire tout
de suite vous minvitz plus vous voulez
pas tuer le suspense c'est ça non voilà
mais je vous dis j'exprime la position
majoritaire du groupe donc il considère
aujourd'hui on a vous étiez g les mais
madame écoutez vous pouvez faire les
commentaires que vous voulez j'exprime
la position de mon groupe qui est celle
de dire nous refusons les propositions
parce que c'est c'est un non sens quand
quand je vous dis que lorsqu'on se
retrouve avec une proposition d'un siège
à Besançon de la région dans lequel
aucun élu ne siègera c'est unique en
France et au monde quand on nous fait la
proposition aujourd'hui qu'on prétend
équilibrer en disant c'est une
projection vers l'avenir qu'on nous
propose une organisation bicite il y a
un mois encore elle nous disait que
l'enseignement la recherche et C
l'étable enç son négociation de coin de
table au sein du Parti socialiste et
puis on se retrouve avec l'enseignement
et la recherche à Dijon enfin tout ça
c'est fait vraiment dans
l'obscure discussion au sein du parti
socialist je dis que la région méritait
mieux que ça je pense qu'on aurait pu
parvenir à un compromis pas
simpement mais bien sûr qu'il faut un
équilibre avec Besançon mais j'avais
fait des propositions moi je proposé que
Besançon soit clairement désigné comme
la capitale économique et comme la
vitrine économique industrielle de notre
région avec un vrai pôle européen
identifié créé en tant que tel et qui
puisse permettre de poursuivre le
relation avec la Suisse d'être au niveau
vers l'Est d'être au niveau national la
Grande Région d'ouverture vers au lieu
de tout ça c'est une répartition petit
bras qui ne satisfait personne moi je
comprends aujourd'hui les franctois
qu'il sont pas content non seulement ils
étent cooccufiés sur l'organisation mais
en plus c'est eux qui payent la note
avec l'augmentation de 42 % des cartes
grises et je comprends la colère de
Monsieur fouser je la partage Jérôme
Durin vous entendez François Sauvadet
c'est un nonsens cette organisation en
de cites est-ce que ça manque pas
effectivement un peu de clarté pour
notamment pour les citoyens ah la clarté
est liée et puis faut arrêter de
dramatiser cette résolution unique cette
répartition des fonctions et des tâches
au sein de la grande région c'est pas
non plus le brexit il y a pas de
catastrophe attendue donc on a une prop
dans votre groupe il y aura des oui il y
aura des non est-ce que votre groupe va
rester il y aura une position
majoritaire il y aura pas d'opposition à
la proposition qui est formulée par la
présidente ça veut dire il y aura
certaines personnes qui vont s'abstenir
on verra on
chix a quand même donné des gages au
bourguignon en prenant monsieur
lagrangeche maintenant comme
vice-président à la place d'un
francontoi avec justement de direction
qui ont quitté Besançon alors qu'elles
étaient annoncées pour Dijon c'est quand
même des gages donné au fr je sais qu'on
est en période d'euro mais une décision
de ce genre là c'est pas le mercato non
plus donc il y a des choix politiques de
fond qui ont été proposés c'est le choix
de l'efficacité c'est le choix du
respect de tous les territoires et dans
tous les territoires il y a pas
seulement besinon et Dijon il y a des
villes moyennes il y a des villages donc
il nous faut un espace métropolitain
dynamique il nous faut une région
solidaire avec tous ces territoires et
une organisation efficace et on respecte
aussi les agents on va pas demand mais
ça veut dire puisquon est dans l'euro on
est dans l'eurau est-ce que l'équipe
joue vraiment collectif où il y aura des
voix dissonances dissonnantes au moment
du vote non non vous allez voir qu'on
est qu'on est collectif on nous attend
d' très divisé j'observe que c'est
plutôt du côté de la droite que que
c'est compliqué cette affaire donc la
gauche va voter pour le Front Nationale
va voter pour une toute petite partie de
la droite va voter pour c'est une
victoire politique pour Mar guide Duffet
je pense que c'est surtout la victoire
d'une méthode c'est qu'elle a choisi de
faire de la pédagogie d'essayer de
respecter chacun et à la he je pense
qu'on on va on va l'emporter si on veut
poursuivre dans la métaphore
footballistique merci merci à tous les
trois merci Catherine emziri nous
reviendrons sur cette session bien sûr
dans nos éditions et rendez-vous sur le
streaming rendez-vous sur internet et
dans nos éditions du 1920 Marie guide
Duffet sera notre invité ce soir c'est
noté ce soir tout à l'heure donc dans le
191 sur France 3 Bourgogne